♪ ♪
>> Katie: WHETHER HE SHOULD
STEP DOWN, AND PROMISING HE
WOULD ABIDE BY THE RESULTS --
WELL, THE VERDICT IS IN, AND 57%
SUPPORT HIS STEPPING DOWN.
THAT COMES AS WE GET A NEW BATCH
OF TWITTER FILES, EXPOSING THE
COZY RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
FBI AND THE SOCIAL MEDIA GIANT.
BULLYING EXECUTIVES WERE NOT
REPORTING STATE PROPAGANDA
ENOUGH.
IT EVEN CAUSED TWITTER'S FORMER
HEAD OF TRUST AND SAFETY TO BE
UNCOMFORTABLE.
HE WAS LIKE I WHO ALSO BANNED
PEOPLE.
TODAY WE LEARNED THE FBI WARNED
TO TWITTER ABOUT INFORMATION
JUST HOURS BEFORE
"THE NEW YORK POST" PUBLISHED AS
HUNTER BIDEN LAPTOP STORY.
DANA, LET'S START THERE.
RIGHT BEFORE THE STORY WAS
PUBLISHED, THE FBI HAD HAVE THE
LAPTOP IN ITS POSSESSION FOR A
YEAR.
>> Dana: I READ THAT WITHIN
THESE FILES, THEY FOUND THAT
THERE WAS A NOTE FROM THE OUSTED
FORMER FBI AND NOW FORMER
TWITTER DEPUTY COUNSEL, JAMES
BAKER, THINKING THE FBI FOR
HELPING THEM GET THE HUNTER
BIDEN LAPTOP STORY PUT AWAY, SO
THAT LOOKS VERY SUSPICIOUS, AND
YOU HAVE TO IMAGINE FOR THE GUY
AT TWITTER, HE WAS EVEN
IRRITATED BY THE FBI, SAYING
GOSH, GUYS, CAN YOU BACK OFF?
YOU ARE STILL A PRIVATE COMPANY.
THE FBI HAD SO MANY AGENTS
LOOKING AT THEM.
I THINK IT'S PRETTY HILARIOUS
THAT THEY SELL FOR SATIRICAL
SITES, AND ACCOUNTS THAT HAD 12
FOLLOWERS.
HOW MANY TIMES HAVE WE MADE FUN
OF PEOPLE RETREATING PEOPLE WHO
HAVE 12 FOLLOWERS?
IF YOU HAVE A MILLION FOLLOWERS
IN YOUR RETWEET SOMEONE'S
COMMENTS AND THEY HAVE 12
FOLLOWERS, WHAT HAVE YOU DONE?
IT DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE.
THERE IS A LOT THERE.
I DO THINK THAT ELON MUSK HAS --
I WOULD NOT SAY THAT HE HAS OPEN
PANDORA'S BOX, BUT HE OPENED THE
BOX, SAYING WOW, THIS THING IS
KIND OF TERRIBLE BUT ALSO
SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BE FIXED.
I WANT TO LAND A GUY ON THE MOON
NEXT WEEK, SO HE NEED SOMEBODY
ELSE TO ACTUALLY RUN THE
DAY-TO-DAY.
>> Katie: GREG, DO YOU THINK
ELON MUSK SHOULD STAY OR GO?
>> Greg: HE'S GOT TO GO.
HE ALREADY KNEW THE OUTCOME.
WHY WOULD HE DO THIS?
PLANNING ON GOING, AND HE USED
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO I GUESS
TEACH US SOMETHING ABOUT MAYBE
HOW TWITTER COULD BE USED IN THE
FUTURE IN TERMS OF MAYBE TWITTER
MAKES DECISIONS.
MAYBE IT IS A HIGH FRAN, HUMAN
BRAIN WHICH PEOPLE VOTE ON
THINGS, THE FUTURE OF VOTING.
IF HE WAS NOT STEPPING DOWN, HE
NEVER WOULD HAVE DONE THIS.
A GREAT WAY TO TURN IT INTO
SOMETHING ELSE.
HE DOES NOT NEED A VISIONARY
BECAUSE THAT IS HIS JOB.
HE IS STILL GOING TO BE RUNNING
THE THING, NO MATTER WHAT.
IF THIS WERE LIKE A TV SHOW, HE
BASICALLY NEEDS A HOUSE TO JUST
KIND OF SHOWS UP.
FRONT OF STORY.
YOU NEED SOMEBODY THAT -- I WAS
THINKING LIKE CHARLES BARKLEY
BECAUSE I CAN'T FIGURE OUT WHERE
HE STANDS ON ANYTHING.
ONE MINUTE HE WILL SAY SOMETHING
SO RIGHT WING, THEN THE NEXT
MINUTE, SO LEFT WING, AND HE IS
AMERICA.
YOU CANNOT HAVE ANYBODY THAT IS
LIKE A REGULAR HERE.
IT HAS TO BE SOMEBODY -- OR
SOMEBODY YOU DON'T KNOW.
>> Dana: SOMEBODY WHO DOES NOT
HAVE A PERSONA.
>> Katie: WE HEAR A LOT FROM
THE LEFT ABOUT MISINFORMATION,
DISINFORMATION.
THE IMPORTANCE OF DEFENDING
DEMOCRACY, AND YET WE ARE SEEING
EVEN MORE OF WHAT WE SUSPECTED,
PROOF OF IT, THAT THE FBI HAD A
HEAVY HAND IN THE LEAD UP TO THE
2020 ELECTION IN SUPPRESSING
INFORMATION THAT COULD HAVE
CHANGED THE ELECTION.
>> Harold: I DON'T KNOW IF IT
WOULD HAVE CHANGED ANYTHING IN
THE ELECTION.
I AM AGAINST CENSORSHIP
REGARDLESS OF WHOM IS
INSTIGATING AT OR WHOM IT MIGHT
HELP IN THE PROCESS, AND SOME
MAY SAY THIS COULD HAVE HELPED
DEMOCRATS.
I AM MOST CONCERNED IT -- IF
THESE REPORTS ARE ACCURATE, AND
I HAVE A REASON TO BELIEVE THAT
THEY MAY NOT BE, WHY WAS THE FBI
AND TWITTER ASKING THEM TO DO
THINGS?
NORMALLY WHEN THEY ARE TRYING TO
GAIN INFORMATION, IT IS EITHER
AN ACTIVE INVESTIGATION
UNDERWAY, OR THERE IS SOMETHING
HAPPENING THAT THEY NEED THAT
INFORMATION FOR TO PREVENT HARM
TO THE COUNTRY.
THAT BURDEN WOULD BE ON THE FBI
TO SHARE WITH THE COUNTRY.
I WILL WITHHOLD JUDGMENT, BUT
THE THINGS THAT WE ARE SEEING,
WHAT THEY ARE RELEASING -- YEAH,
EXACTLY.
ALL OF THIS IS TROUBLING, AND I
THINK IT DESERVES AN ANSWER.
>> Katie: THE ONE PERSON
TRYING TO GET ANSWERS --
>> Harold: I AGREE WITH GREG.
HE PROBABLY KNEW THE OUTCOME,
BUT HE SAID HE'S GOT A PRETTY
COMPELLING REASON.
>> Katie: WHEN THOSE POLLS
COME OUT, HE DOES WHAT THEY SAY.
JESSE, SOMEONE WHO WANTS TO TRY
TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT THIS ISSUE
WITH THE FBI INFLUENCING
TWITTER, KEVIN McCARTHY.
LET'S LISTEN TO WHAT HE SAID.
WHAT HE IS GOING TO DO.
WE WILL GET YOUR TAKE.
>> WE ARE GOING TO DO MORE THAN
JUST SUBPOENA THEM.
WE ARE GOING TO CHANGE THE
COURSE OF WHERE THE FBI IS
TODAY.
THEY BECAME AN CODE PRIVATE
COMPANIES BECOME A POLITICAL ARM
OF THEM, TO GO AFTER
INDIVIDUALS, WITH NO
REPERCUSSIONS FOR INDIVIDUALS
THAT KNOW IT'S HAPPENING, BUT IT
RAISES MORE QUESTIONS.
>> Katie: JESSE?
>> Jesse: YOU ARE NEVER GOING
TO BE THE FBI.
THEY ARE JUST TOO POWERFUL.
AND I'M GOING TO GET MY HOPES
UP, AND MY HEART IS GOING TO GET
BROKEN.
>> Greg: HOW MANY TIMES HAS
THAT HAPPEN?
>> Jesse: DAY AFTER DAY AFTER
DAY.
YOU FELL INTO TWITTER
HEADQUARTERS, AND YOUR FBI BADGE
BASICALLY WORKS THERE.
YES, SIR, I WILL DO WHATEVER YOU
WANT.
IT'S CRAZY.
MORE FBI AGENTS IN TWITTER THAN
THERE ARE STANFORD GRADUATES.
WE WILL WEED THEM OUT, BUT IT IS
GOING TO TAKE A WHILE.
MUSK CANNOT POLL TWITTER.
IT SKEWS ATHEIST FEMALE.
OVEREDUCATED.
WE'VE SEEN THE METRICS ON IT.
IT IS MOSTLY SINGLE WOMEN THAT
HAVE GRADUATE DEGREES.
>> Katie: THAT'S TRUE.
>> Jesse: THAT'S LIKE ME
RUNNING FOR GOVERNOR OF VERMONT.
I AM NEVER GOING TO WIN THAT.
>> Dana: THEY HAVE A
REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR NOW.
>> Jesse: I HAVE A FRIEND WHO
IS A TURNAROUND ARTIST.
THEY HIRE HIM TO GO IN FOR TWO
YEARS ENTERING THE PLACE AROUND,
JUST HIRE A BUNCH OF PEOPLE,
CHEESE PROFITS, AND THEN GET THE
HELL OUT OF THERE.
THAT IS WHAT MUSK IS.
GET OUT OF THERE, FIND OUT ALL
THE CRIMES THAT HAVE BEEN
COMMITTED, MAKE IT PROFITABLE,
AND THEN SKEDADDLE.
HE IS WORTH BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
HE'S GOT INVESTORS.
REPUBLICANS HAVE A LOT OF MONEY
IN TESLA.
ALL THESE COMPANIES.
THEY DO NOT WANT TO HEAR THE CEO
SPOUTING OFF ABOUT GOD KNOWS
WHAT ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
THEY LIKE QUIET, RICH GUYS TO
STAY ON THE SIDELINES.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW WHO IS A
GOOD TURNAROUND ARTIST?
BRIAN KILMEADE.
WHENEVER I SEE HIM, I
TURNAROUND.
>> Dana: YOU CAN FIND THEM ALL
EVERYWHERE.
TH